pendant plusieurs semaines en France la
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites a fait la Une le projet de loi
adoptait le 20 mars à l'Assemblée
nationale relève l'âge légal de départ à
la retraite à 64 ans une mesure à
laquelle s'oppose plus de 2/3 des
Français et à l'international alors
comment ça se passe déjà quand on parle
de la retraite il faut comprendre à quel
système on a affaire le financement peut
s'organiser de deux manières différentes
premièrement il y a la répartition c'est
un système public dans lequel le
financement des retraites fonctionne sur
une solidarité intergénérationnelle
c'est à dire que les cotisations des
travailleurs et des employeurs financent
les pensions des retraités ensuite il y
a le financement par capitalisation dans
lequel les actifs épargnent pour leur
propre retraite dans ce cas des fonds de
pension privée gère cette épargne on a
deux grands modèles dans certains pays
comme la France l'Italie l'Allemagne la
quasi-totalité des retraites
financer par répartition et dans
d'autres pays comme les États-Unis le
Royaume-Uni il y a un système public par
répartition compléter par des systèmes
par capitalisation autre cas intéressant
l'Inde ou des régimes obligatoires par
capitalisation couvre environ 12% des
actifs c'est à dire que le reste soit
88% de la population indienne ne
bénéficie pas d'un système de retraite
dans les pays en développement une
grande partie du travail se fait sous
forme informelle c'est-à-dire dans
l'agriculture dans le commerce dans la
petite industrie les personnes
travaillent sans être soumis à aucune
législation ne paye pas de cotisation
sociale et en échange si on peut dire
ils n'ont pas droit à une retraite à
l'échelle mondiale on estime qu'environ
60% des actifs sont dans un système
informel et donc les systèmes organisés
de retraite ne couvrent que 40%
une fois vu cela c'est bien sûr l'âge du
départ à la retraite qui nous intéresse
or lorsque l'on parle d'âge de départ à
la retraite cela peut recouper des
réalités bien différentes il faut donc
être attentif à ce que l'on dit et
éviter les comparaisons trop rapides par
exemple si l'on s'intéresse à l'âge
légal de départ à la retraite on note
que la France avec ce qu'il y a encore
peu de temps ses 62 ans se situait
effectivement dans la moyenne basse
comme les États-Unis ou le Brésil pour
les femmes mais là je légale est
différent de l'âge réel de départ à la
retraite c'est-à-dire l'âge de sortie
effective du marché du travail
directement lié au taux d'emploi des
seniors ainsi l'écart souvent cités
entre les 62 ans en France et les 67 ans
en Allemagne se réduit considérablement
si l'on regarde l'âge de sortie du
marché du travail dans les deux pays
soit respectivement près de 61 ans et 63
ans
par ailleurs dans certains pays comme
c'est le cas en France le choix du
départ à la retraite est également
influencé par l'existence de décote qui
incite à repousser l'âge du départ afin
de prétendre à une retraite complète
mais finalement des parts tardif ou non
comment peut-on juger de l'efficacité du
système de retraite de tel ou tel pays
et bien c'est au conditions de vie des
retraités qu'il faut s'intéresser un
système de retraite doit avoir
l'objectif que tous les retraités
échappent à la pauvreté et le deuxième
objectif c'est que les retraités et à
peu près le même niveau de vie que les
actifs donc on a ces deux indicateurs le
niveau de vie relatif des retraités et
le taux de pauvreté on a des pays très
généreux la France
l'Italie la Grèce dans lequel les
retraités ont le même niveau de vie que
les actifs et on a beaucoup de pays où
en fait les retraités ont un niveau de
vie plus bas en Allemagne les retraités
au niveau de vie plus bas de 10% de
celui objectifs aux États-Unis plus bas
de 5% et le pire si on peut dire c'est
la Corée ou les retraités au niveau de
vie inférieure de 35% à celui des actifs
en cette matière la France est donc la
championne avec un taux de pauvreté de 4
% en deuxième place l'Allemagne avec un
taux à 9 % on note les États-Unis et la
Chine avec des taux à respectivement 23%
et 39%. un sénior a donc 6 fois plus de
risques d'être en situation de pauvreté
aux États-Unis qu'en France et près de
10 fois plus de risques en Chine en
France bref pour conclure lorsqu'on
parle de la retraite les choses sont
bien souvent plus compliquées qu'il n'y
paraît et tout ça risque encore de se
compliquer à l'avenir on a deux types de
défis le premier c'est que dans un très
grand nombre de pays émergents la
priorité c'est de formaliser l'activité
de faire que la quasi-totalité des
personnes sont effectivement couvertes
dans les pays
développer le grand enjeu c'est le fait
que la population vieillit on va avoir
de plus en plus de personnes
âgées et donc les pays sont tous
confrontés à la même question est-ce que
on reporte l'âge de départ à la retraite
sachant que à partir d'un certain âge de
personnes âgées ont du mal à travailler
est-ce que on augmente les taux de
cotisation ce que souvent les actifs ont
du mal à supporter ou est-ce qu'on
baisse le niveau des pensions ce qui
veut dire que à l'avenir on aurait de
plus en plus de retraités pauvres
[Musique]